everyone knows about the Incredible Hulk
but what about the sensational she-hulk
Bruce banners cousin Jennifer Walters
aka she-hulk has done everything from
kicking around with Marvel's first
family to flying around the galaxy as a
space lawyer let's explore the untold
truth of she-hulk legal legacy
considering how successful the Hulk has
been for Marvel it stands to reason that
they want to fill the Green giant's
world with some supporting players but
it actually took the threat of losing
the rights to a lady hope that pushed
the publisher into actually making it
happen with the Incredible Hulk TV
series blowing up in the late 70s Marvel
started to worry CBS might try to spin
off a female led series just like how
the Six Million Dollar Man led to the
Bionic Woman in order to retain control
Marvel beat them to the punch and
created she-hulk before anyone could
develop the idea though as female
versions of existing characters go no
one beats mode AM original fourth wall
breaker
everyone loves Deadpool in large part
because the antihero cracks jokes and
talks directly to viewers about how
ridiculous comics can be but she-hulk
helped pioneer that concept in the pages
of sensational she-hulk for 60 issues in
the 1980s several years before Wade
Wilson even first showed up the cover of
the first issue actually featured
she-hulk holding a copy of a previous
standalone title telling readers this is
your second chance if you don't buy my
book this time I'm going to come to your
house and rip up all your x-men
sensational she-hulk wasn't afraid to
get weird and often featured she-hulk
talking directly to readers as well as
her own writers and artists when the
series was canceled with issue 16
she-hulk made good on her promise and
came back for the readers x-men comics
Marvel's fashion icon John Byrne
sensational she-hulk series was never
afraid to try out unusual things and its
acclaim the late-1980s run is known for
establishing much of the personality and
look fans have come to love about
Jennifer Walters sensational she-hulk
cast the green super heroine as a
fashion icon of sorts drawing
comparisons to Melanie Griffith
occasionally changing up her attire four
or five times per issue when she wasn't
out busting up supervillains she was
wearing classic early 90s styles like
stylish dresses and pant suits or on one
particular strange occasion nearly
nothing during four full pages of jump
roping you can practically hear the
Nerds breathing heavily when you look at
those pages
Oh loneliness and cheeseburgers very
dangerous Mick as if the books weren't
unusual enough readers only had to turn
to the back pages to find the most
unfortunately named letter pages of all
time considering that the comic was
about a woman with traditionally
masculine hockey traits that fan mail
section it was called [ __ ] one of
Stanley's last great creations greetings
true believers I'm Stan Lee throughout
the 1960's comics legend Stan Lee
co-created many of the a-list heroes on
Marvel's roster he had a hand in Iron
Man spider-man the Fantastic Four the
Hulk Black Panther Hawkeye and the x-men
just to name a few but after that
remarkable run Lee didn't create a
character for more than a decade until
she Hulk Lee co-created the character of
Jennifer Walters with John Buscemi in
1980 and she made a debut in savage
she-hulk she's one of the last truly
successful characters Lee created unless
of course you can't stripper Ella which
we don't Ania should you substitute
thing she-hulk has been a member of
several different teams over the years
one of the most interesting the
Fantastic Four
though Marvel's first family is
typically comprised of mr. fantastic the
Human Torch Invisible Woman and the
thing she-hulk joined the roster as a
resident strong woman when the thing
temporarily left the team she started
holding down the force in his absence
and Fantastic Four issue 265 even after
that first stint came to an end she
eventually worked with the Future
Foundation and teamed up more than a few
times of the FF mrs. man-wolf she-hulk
has had love connections with more than
a few heroes and villains across the
Marvel roster but one of the most
interesting relationships with her brief
barrage to John Jameson son of
spider-man stalwart Jay jonah Jameson
John has been portrayed as everything
from an astronaut to a man wolf over the
decades but the relationship didn't last
it's true what they say
relationships between giant green
lawyers and werewolf astronauts are
doomed from the start
she faced off against daredevil there
are two most prominent lawyers in the
Marvel Universe and it's crazy to think
it took until 2014 for she-hulk and
daredevil to finally face off in the
courtroom the two met in a case
involving Steve Rogers aka Captain
America who had lost his youth and
powers writer Charles Soule managed the
tricky feat of balancing the dueling
attorneys abilities both super and legal
cinematic she-hulk
while the character never wound up in
the live-action Incredible Hulk TV
series Marvel did try to bring her to
the silver screen in the late 80s the
project got far enough along into
development for the studio to shoot some
concept photo starving Brigitte Nielsen
it was even announced as an upcoming
project at the Cannes Film Festival in
1991 along with her would-be sequel to
Dolph Lundgren's Punisher movie
production fell apart due to a lack of
interest and Marvel's terrible track
record in the 90s as for Nielsen it was
certainly an interesting look for
she-hulk they basically just threw her
into a green bodysuit and you know what
they say life imitates art years after
her involvement with the project ended
Nielsen found herself in a relationship
not unlike one of she-hulk's many
romantic misadventures thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]